y de ahí me trajeron para que
transitoriamente hasta la fecha del 97
me encuentro aquí de derrumbe en
derrumbe a sí mismo
[Música]
a ver si quitamos ustedes
pero realmente nosotros nos acostamos
con este molde no amanecer yo pedí un
hijo no quisiera perder mi niña es una
línea con problema pero quiero conservar
de su vida que madre no quiere conservar
la vida si
entiende realmente nosotros lo que
queremos es una ayuda que nos saquen de
aquí y nos den una vida más placentera
donde nosotros podamos volver con
tranquilidad
[Música]
no es recomendable que -dijo- personas
ahí debido a que
poco a poco en mayor medida van a seguir
ocurriendo derrumbes parciales en los
distintos niveles de la edificación
[Música]
y